The Ballad vault for the foil
consistency was supported by thousand
nine hundred and sixty-five the invalid
built was 177 I almond Taylor as the
deputy returning officer for the Floyd
constituency hereby declare that at the
election the number of votes for each
candidate was as follows John Doherty
Alliance party 847 it for seven mark
Durkin SDLP Social Democratic and Labour
Party eighteen thousand and eighty seven
one eight zero eight seven
Sean Harkin people before profit
Alliance 1377 one three seven seven
alicia McCallion Sinn Fein eighteen
thousand two hundred and fifty-six
[Applause]
Oh
Oh
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
one eight two five six American
Democratic Unionist Party DUP 7390 eight
seven three nine eight I declare that
Alicia mccallion is returned to serve in
forum
[Applause]
[Music]
the constituency okay
I don't know that they yell at me brands
here folks before a start I wanna
acknowledge their going MP for the city
mark has being a public representative
and and daring for a large number of
years and he has served it well but I
can't not express my extreme delight at
the end the first ever Republican MP
ever
[Applause]
it's been an absolute privilege had been
given this opportunity and an even
bigger privilege for the electorate to
come out today and vote for me and the
numbers that they have and I want to
make it clear that I will represent
every single person in this constituency
I might take this opportunity to thank
the team of activists to have been with
me every step of the way of this
campaign this has been an amazing
campaign for Republicans in this city
every single one of them was a day and
and I want to take the opportunity now
you see
[Music]
folks republicans in this city have had
a difficult start to the year there's no
doubt about it
we've lost or fram'd we lost earlier and
we lost our inspiration but he guided us
every step of the way through this
election has memory loves on and every
single one of us and martin we did this
for you this is part of Martin's legacy
in this city before the election we told
the electorate that if I was booted on
your vote none part of team champagne
I'm delighted no to be part of that team
again and they represent people of this
city in places where it will actually
matter I'm delighted to be working
beside and I want to thank and
acknowledge the role of our leader in
the north Michelle O'Neill who was with
us here tonight I thank her leadership
that she's shown throughout this
campaign has been incredible it's
certainly been great as an older woman
to get the support that I have got from
Michelle and indeed the entire party so
folks it's been a long day it's been a
magnificent day but I'm not going to
keep you too much longer because there's
party
[Applause]